>>> RIGHT NOW, MANY RUSSIANS ARE
SCRAMBLING TO LEAVE THUR
COUNTRY.
AMID FEARS THAT THE NATION'S
BORDERS MAY SOON BE CLOSED OFF.
NEW SATELLITE IMAGES SHOW A LINE
OF TRAFFIC THAT SPANNED NEARLY
10 MILES AS PEOPLE WAIT TO CROSS
INTO THE NEIGHBORING COUNTRY OF
GEORGIA.
THE KREMLIN COULD BAN MILITARY
AGE MEN FROM LEAVING THE
COUNTRY.
AS SOON AS TODAY.
THE RUSH TO CALL UP NEW TROOPS
IS SPLITTING FAMILIES APART.
CNN OBTAINED VIDEO OF A GROOM
FORCED TO SAY GOOD-BYE TO HIS
NEW WIFE JUST BEFORE JOINING THE
MILITARY THERE.
RIGHT AFTER THEIR WEDDING.
JOINING ME NOW IS BRILL BROWDER,
THE CEO OF HERMITAGE CAPITAL
MANAGEMENT AND FORMERLY RUSSIA'S
BIGGEST FOREIGN INVESTOR.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU ON TODAY.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE.
>> YOU'VE BEEN A LONG TIME
PRESIDENT IN RUSSIA, OBSERVER OF
IT AND CONTACT AND DISPUTES WITH
SENIOR OFFICIALS IN RUSSIA.
WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE FLEEING THE
COUNTRY.
BY THE CARLOAD, RIGHT.
MILES LONG LINES.
WE'RE SEEING SOME PROTESTS IN
THE COUNTRY AND EVEN SEE
SOMETHING OFFICIALS BEGIN TO
HAVE PUBLIC CRITICISM OF THE
MOBILIZATION AND EVEN THE
RUSSIAN LEADERSHIP.
IS THE OPPOSITION TO PUTIN TODAY
STRONGER, MORE CREDIBLE THAN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST?
>> FOR SURE IT IS.
THE IDEA AND PUTIN IS CROSSED
THE RUBICON, THE IDEA OF SENDING
MEN, BETWEEN THE AGES OF 18 AND
60 TO BE CANNON FODDER AND DYING
ON THE -- IN THE WAR IN UKRAINE
IS SOMETHING THAT EFFECTS EVERY
SINGLE MALE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THAT REALLY DOES BRING IT
HOME, THAT THIS IS NO LONGER A
THEORETICAL ISSUE THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S DECISIONS AND HIS BAD
DECISIONS ARE EFFECTING
EVERYONE'S LIFE PROFOUNDLY.
>> OKAY.
SO MORE CREDIBLE BUT MORE OF A
THREAT, A GENUINE THREAT TO
PUTIN'S LEADERSHIP OR CAN HE PUT
THIS DOWN?
>> WELL PUTIN IS A VERY
EFFECTIVE DICTATOR.
HE HAS PUT DOWN MANY OTHER
UPRISINGS AND DISCONTENT IN THE
PAST.
THERE WERE TIMES WHEN HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS WERE MARCHING
THROUGH THE STREET OF MOSCOW AND
HE TEAR RISED HIS OWN CITIZENS
AND TAKING THEM AND PUTTING THEM
IN JAIL FOR TEN YEARS AND
SENTING A MESSAGE TOO EVERYBODY
ELSE, THAT WILL HAPPEN TO YOU.
IN THIS CASE, PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
OF DYING ON THE FRONT.
HAVING SAID THAT, PUTIN IS A
GOOD DICTATOR.
HE'S VERY GOOD AT REPRESSING
PEOPLE.
HE'S VERY GOOD AT SCARING PEOPLE
AND HE WILL USE THE ENTIRETY OF
HIS REPRESSION MACHINE TO GO
AFTER PEOPLE AND MY BET IS THAT
HE SUCCEEDS.
WE'VE SEEN ANOTHER COUNTRIES, IN
IRAN, IN NORTH KOREA THAT A
DICTATOR COULD STAY IN POWER FOR
A VERY LONG TIME.
SO I WOULDN'T BE BETTING AGAINST
PUTIN RIGHT NOW IN SPITE OF THE
IMAGES.
>> WE'RE SEEING AN ALARMING
SERIES OF THREATS IN PUBLIC BY
SENIOR RUSSIAN OFFICIALS RIGHT
UP TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE USE
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
-- THE LATEST TO SAY THAT RUSSIA
WOULD USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO
PROTECT THE EXISTENCE OF OUR
STATE AS THE AREAS IN THE
EASTERN PART OF THE COUNTRY WILL
HAVE SHAM ELECTIONS TO MAKE THEM
PART OF THE RUSSIAN STATE.
ARE RUSSIAN LEADERS LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK TO JUSTIFY THE USE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
>> WHAT THEY'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
IS DIGGING INTO OUR BIGGEST
FEARS AND WORRIES BY USING THE
N-WORD.
TO USE TO TALK ABOUT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IS SOMETHING THAT NOBODY
HAS DONE BEFORE.
SO, THEY'VE NOW PUT IT ON THE
TABLE.
BUT BEFORE WE START CAPITULATING
AND FOLDING AND GETTING SCARED
AWAY, WE SHOULD JUST THINK FOR A
SECOND ABOUT WHAT WOULD ACTUALLY
HAPPEN IF THEY DID USE UNUSUAL
WEAPONS.
FIRST THING THAT WOULD HAPPEN,
THE WIND BLOWS FROM WEST TO EAST
AND SO THE FALLOUT WOULD GO OVER
RUSSIA.
THE SECOND THING THAT WOULD
HAPPEN IS THAT PUTIN WOULD LOSE
THE ENTIRE SUPPORT OF ALL OF THE
NON-ALIGNED COUNTRIES, THE INDIA
AND THE CHINA AND THE AFRICA, ET
CETERA.
AND THIRD, IT IS NOT CLEAR THAT
HE WOULD ACTUALLY FURTHER HIS
MILITARY GOALS.
HE WOULDN'T END UP WITH UKRAINE
BY KILLING A MILLION PEOPLE.
HE WOULD JUST END UP IN A
TOTALLY DESPERATE ISOLATED
SITUATION.
AND SO, I THINK THAT RIGHT NOW
THERE IS A LOT OF ESCALATION
THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN BETWEEN
WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND ALL OF
THE TERRIBLE THREATS THAT
THEY'RE MAKING.
>> THE TROUBLE IS THAT HE'S
ALREADY IN AN ISOLATED, WEAKENED
SPACE.
YOU SAID EARLY ON THAT UKRAINE
WOULD PUSH BACK AND PUSH BACK
HARD AND THEY'VE PROVEN TO DO SO
AND YOU COULD MAKE A STRONG
ARGUMENT THAT PUTIN HAS LOST
THIS WAR STRATEGICALLY.
AT LEAST TO THIS POINT.
IN YOUR VIEW, HAS HE LOST, AND
WOULD HE ACCEPT LOSS?
>> HE DEFINITELY WOULDN'T ACCEPT
LOSS.
THE REASON WHY HE WENT INTO THIS
WAR BECAUSE HE WAS WORRIED HIS
CITIZENS RISING UP AGAINST HIM
BECAUSE OF 22 YEARS OF STEALING
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY.
HE WAS BASICALLY, HE HAD CREATED
A IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION.
AND SO HE DID WHAT MOST
DICTATORS DO.
HE PULLED INTO THE DICTATOR'S
PLAYBOOK AND CREATED A FOREIGN N
ENEMY TO START A WAR BECAUSE HE
WANTED PEOPLE TO SUPPORT HIM.
FOR A WHILE HE HAD 80% POPULAR
SUPPORT.
AND NOW HE'S LOSING THE WAR AND
HE LOOKS WEAK AND WHAT DOES HE
DO INTO THIS SITUATION?
HE'S GOT TO THROW EVERYTHING
ELSE HE'S GOT AT IT WHICH IS WHY
HE'S DRAFTED BETWEEN 300,000 AND
A MILLION ABLE-BODIED MEN TO
SHOW UP AT THE FRONT.
HE HAS A LOT OF MONEY.
HE'S BUYING EQUIPMENT FROM IRAN
AND NORTH KOREA.
AND LE THROW EVERYTHING HE HAS
AT THIS BECAUSE THERE IS NO WAY
HE COULD SHOW WEAKNESS, BECAUSE
IF HE DOES SHOW WEAKNESS TO THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE, THEY WILL GET
RID OF HIM AND IF THEY GET RID
OF HIM HE DIES.
>> BILL BROWDER GOOD TO DRAW ON
YOUR EXPERIENCE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> JIM, THAT WAS FASCINATING.
I MEAN GIVEN BILL'S EXPERIENCE
WITH THE PUTIN REGIME.
WERE YOU SURPRISED, I MEAN HIS
COMMENT ALSO ABOUT THE BLOWBACK
FROM ANY POTENTIAL USE OF A
NUCLEAR WEAPON BY RUSSIA WAS
INTERESTING AND ONE I HAVEN'T
HEARD MANY TAKE.
>> AND EVEN PUTIN KNOWS WHAT A
BLOW BACK WOULD BE, INCLUDING
FROM PARTNER